hey pop what's up fool what's up fool
podcast welcome to the Watson full
podcast on Wednesday if you're watching
a live or Friday we listen to on Friday
or morning influenced to one on morn
Monday morning or you probably listening
to this right now in October of two
thousand twenty three and barely getting
started on a podcast and you catching up
so Wow
welcome either way welcome to the what's
up fool podcast and you if you if you
up-to-date you know who our guest is
right now guest coho co-host
Rodrigo's co-host Roger hey thank you
for having me back bro well the do
choices here yeah man
these ice bars is over there yeah the
fact we're gonna fight Johnny but no
sleep he's like stalking the littles on
their anniversary trip or something
in Portland I mean you know what's going
on me you didn't take me huh dude get a
lady already done and I don't know if
that's true but I don't know if they're
seeing each other but he was hiding a
new denim jacket don't even say them
dawg
that's so funny that jacket always comes
up most well Felipe that jean jacket
always comes up in conversation like it
caused some tension right I don't want
to bet I feel like stealin a good
charity
Johnny was trying to be a playboy though
right and then like trying to get a
bunch of chicks and never worked and
like it's like the Kramer jacket and
then like now he's like trying to you
know get one chick normal I think if
you're like not a player it's not in
your blood you can't be a player at all
yeah man effect and if you are a player
will be nervous time huh Kim Beverly
looking bad did you ever call him out on
the podcast for not telling us he was
going on a date in New York I remember I
remember like he popped it up did we
talk about that No
if it's not a done deal dog what are you
going over there holding hands for dog
yeah I don't take anybody out for
lobster bro speaking about that guy
happen dude we're on the street Spanish
yo ah not this bad the show I don't know
man speaking Spanish but remember when I
I'm shaking bro oh yeah there was an
arrest
mogera it was an arrest the rest were
arrested Willy do whatever in El Paso
the we were about to a passable yeah
well I guess you went there twice after
kind of got cocky and this last time
facts yes but he was he was uh well I
mean if you live in Texas court records
only pay five bucks but uh yeah I got
two sources I and he was arrested but I
guess you know let go to do a shows
Thursday through Sunday but yeah he
finally caught the caper bro I'll be
catching somebody called oh yeah I don't
know dude but I think that probably was
a warrant for his arrest he posted and
you know some detectives like dude I
gotta get this guy get the little guy
some justice some lady named Nikki Tara
called Rick Warren cold all my buddies
on the force man my good oh man it's
like but I mean like you know I mean a
lot of stuffs been happening in El Paso
so that's kind of minor right give me a
slap on the wrist bro
it made me pay a fine bro it made me hit
him again bro the Camellia server at the
commissary bro we show a week I'm gonna
put in the new air conditioner he has to
go to court now right yeah probably yeah
I don't know see I don't know what the
deal is but you know well you probably
look up the the name on and see if what
the docket says on their website your
prosecutorial not how discharged
arrested in charge so yes
he's probably got pulling they probably
just like bail them out for free look
like yo you so funny
Willie if he had pool he wouldn't got
arrested yes because anybody that's
going through any court case you can go
to the county and look it up and it'll
pop up what we call don't know yeah now
bro put him on the line I'm gonna go
walk a doe me all right
he's a morning radio 4 port with not
barred we should invite him him against
might not pass without me would he do
radio him he's gonna be out here if he
should be out here he was telling me he
knows roll over that station he though
he the morning I was asleep
no passes her second thing maybe you
could do a phoner hit him Oh bro I want
to shock him
what is up with those guys how come
you're wearing this I don't know Billy
don't bring us out here you come and
taste old old proper Spanish speaking
Toby they Tom Leykis all you sleeping
for morning radio taking that net
what's up fool he was buzz buzz in the
morning yeah they had that girl right
there she said she were from Palmdale
there was an eye from India she was
saying she was from LA and then she's
all worried were you from Coachella
everybody the Greater Los Angeles area
really spreads out that way doesn't it
so many people say do that my home he
lives out in no central brush is far
like 30 minutes from the Raju that
border entrance yeah
some come to the show in kitchen hey I
will rock which art kitchen Resort
Winter Haven California October 5th
Imperial Valley right there yeah I was
mad I got like what's up everybody first
of all man thank you everyone for coming
out to the show last night in Riverside
at the Riverside mean it mean is suppose
center-right life Art Center live Art
Center it was packed your name people
there were no seats they store not $10
show the every month every month the
best green comedy and man is a good date
man $10
they got wine beer chips nachos nachos
pretty much they got the same food they
get the bar recover yeah the sound of a
strings up same-same of the information
do you see the Red Hot Cheetos the
nachos cheese sauce yeah
that's delicious but actually gave me
cancer so [ __ ] yeah I do like pool like
pool food right hmm who didn't show it
was for us for us he was a house for us
Contreras and Angel Hara for Pomona our
friend of ours a lady and loose Passos
loose Passos she left before signing
autographs yeah she had a bail out
myself and then to go work for LA go to
the bathroom who's throwing some mean
duds now I caught on Facebook he's
getting bored I'll clean with a little
bling a lot of jokes but some of them
are good some of them I like what man so
what are complaints the complaints
giving bull run away bro what somebody
comes with positives oh it's like dude
you're over here recovery dog busting
you know Flaco yeah I met him once or
twice yeah he's a skinny ass do with the
suit
oh yeah dude I just found out last time
I was on here that he has a pacemaker
what you know that's that's crazy but
you know yeah he grew up in a garage but
hopefully they can give him like an
Ironman one that way he could live for
like 200 years and just [ __ ] [ __ ]
for like moderation
oh [ __ ] could you put on that um that
Deena gave you I love garden when you're
waiting for a table
oh yeah man I really knows only fake
Iron Man bro hey Tecna
what's up pool take care buddy who
showed up to the San Jose improv five
sold-out show and the other one would
have full butt [ __ ] you guys showed up
on Sunday man I hate like far okay like
eight burritos when I was there three
from the bigs and the rebel from the
other place in the last salsa boy turned
him I worked out on a treadmill no I did
it I did ten laps on the pole
shut up - Rachel Wolfson oh she's on the
show also uh Pete munos and jolly Pena
with a long-ass beard and other fool
with a longer beard or name which was
the meaningful the world the beard a
little fat boy with a chili a nose he
would do it oh sweet great talking with
you
yeah Pete means of reality on Instagram
memes are really a lot of people right
loves animals they are talking about
shrooms everybody some chocolates that
guys didn't give me some chocolates and
the shroom says he said last eight hours
I don't wanna be out for that long take
half yeah I take half for to be eight
hours
no it'll be half the dosage of whatever
he gives you though if he says whatever
he gives gonna be eight hours just break
that shouldn't have I'll split at least
or something yeah cuz I mean usually a
good trip lasts five hours over five
hours for good treatment like a good one
dawg like a solid one yeah it starts
creeping in on you and then it goes full
force and then it dips down
I remember having one word it was so
amazing bro like like I always want to
go to the blankets or do be cozy dawg
that's what it's all about that bad no
it's a [ __ ] you got dude you it's all
like [ __ ] sent your sense frees your
sense your senses dogs like you know you
activate the other sense a little bit
different dimensions don't so wherever
it takes you to and basically you eat
that stuff and it poisons you gives you
that reaction and then you [ __ ] come
down and you know go back to reality one
of those fools were all talking about
DMT and all that [ __ ] I don't want to do
actually no I'm gonna [ __ ] my pants yeah
Davey will be [ __ ] themselves on TNT
what uh Iowa Iowa
three days of clean up folks give me a
diaper roll but yeah dude [ __ ] uh
shrooms of trippin they're different oh
they're just like buds dog it's there's
different strains and different types
and you know and that homeboy was
talking about Johnny Benny I was talking
about that uh
eat some fresh dog out there and they
know what cons like dude I don't know
about all that
yeah I'm good on that there's some
people that like flip over the couch and
just eat it fly from one of the stem is
like growing out of the earth the root
yeah I'm good yeah I'm good I'm not any
cash but now you can make your own or
grow your own you know you put them into
half kits do it so and again that's the
next little thing that they're trying to
get aa legal and all these states where
marijuana is already yeah they just
passed it in Colorado right I believe so
yeah there's legally shrooms but I think
like you know some people micro dose but
I don't think micro doses does too much
cuz that one night I just took that
little cap and little stem like those
little small ones and I tripped a little
bit but not even tripped it was just
more like ah dude I heard the music
better and then like the the light with
it off was just a little different color
got sunglasses on that was it it only
lasted 45 minutes took about two hours
it's definitely a movement when we were
that one time on Halloween and we're all
screwed out I musta ate split a half
eight with Lisa and you thought there
for my cuz I'm moving too much yeah I
like moving a lot I don't like being
around a lot of people and everyone was
moving and I felt really really good but
I also felt good you know even better
when I was just laid in the room at
least I watching the clothing counselor
Third Kind
yeah see that's the [ __ ] you have to
watch or watch a Grateful Dead movie dog
like dude but I had a bad trip that one
time I did that's the last time you had
a shroom no I've done it a couple times
after but never that time but you know I
was over there in the center divider
dude I felt like I was gonna fall off
the earth but also there was a lot of
weird energy there call out the urns
Lassa those people that have those like
anti-gay signs in car yeah dude that's
like do that like sent me even deep
brows I to eat and there were so many
cops around I thought they're gonna bust
me how's that one who copper look pretty
dude everybody thought he was a fake cop
he was a real cop though so cop that you
look handsome like a Ken doll he had a
much
like a lock up one little wrestlers from
the 1910s and he look fake boy the real
sheriff look like me without like those
like he they carved him like he looked
like those little like those new uh you
know sex dolls whatever all cleaned up
yeah
the homie saw aliens on shrooms he was
in the Sedona by those red rocks yeah he
saw like a bunch of like like it looked
like shooting stars but like barely
above your head and they were like no
bro is true but then I looked it up as a
video of like a news channel penny now
for like the good night at night and you
can see those exact same like [ __ ]
like tracers yeah they're trying to say
they were like doves that were being
illuminated by like the lights and I
don't believe in aliens what so [ __ ]
take me to your employer take me to your
boss I don't believe it do we would have
seen him by now they're only gonna land
by Air Force bases full come on
everybody's a hard-on for all these
conspiracy freak out man like dude good
lagana even if they are aliens you see
there is a lien you can't show them
around because they don't mean that
religions the [ __ ] lie yeah that one
alien will just change everything
there'll be riots bro people want their
money back from Joel Osteen people want
their money from the Archdiocese you
know what their money from the Christian
people
everybody want the money back but was
the alien shows up and said hey I'm here
people will just be pissed off at God
like because you realize they got it
that real damn bro you think there would
be mass chaos bro I think like the
preachers are so like conniving like
crafty that they'll be like yo man this
is the God these are our children too
they own the media so they say that this
is the message from God repent the
revelation is here DOS pilas Omaha bro
yeah and then with all these fools in
their social media videos and stuff for
like the last what five six seven years
nobody has any and it's that same grainy
[ __ ] that they showed on channel 7
Eyewitness News a boy years ago people
always say that this is the
trash of this distraction live
distraction with discretion without they
no distraction man you are distracted
yeah that's it
just focus on your life man go to work
go to work pay your bills on time buy
some food go for a walk take a deep
breath live live man you can't leave me
livin life about what distracted who
just refocus on yourself
do you don't get distracted eh you're
distracting yourself by just getting
other people to know about being
distracted just focus on yourself and
live a good life yeah yeah and then keep
on looking at advertising keep on buying
Colgate keep on buying a Toyota Prius
whatever it is you have to buy to
survive and that's what it is you know
people always say that our man these
people support rub these every time man
anybody any big company supports the big
shot [ __ ] yeah you were they gotta make
money
McDonagh support Obama my daughter
supported Bush people people gonna say
all this who supports who and nobody's
gonna stop eating a cheeseburger
nobody's gonna stop drinking coke or
working out nobody's gonna go stop go to
the Olive Garden because they deported
ten people I don't know nobody's gonna
stop doing anything because we're a
bunch of [ __ ] man everybody dude
everybody I ate you think I'm gonna go
out there and it cost me losing my phone
hell no - come on dogs don't live true
food a Cabernet that's me I'm off of a
lost everything to gain everything
exactly
he's the Biggest Loser winner dog people
love McDonald's let me tell ya I'm sorry
this is important my grandma bro
I bet you after they deported a bunch of
people they're all sad when you eat at
McDonald's yeah you didn't tell me our
Burger King bro quarter pounder is a
bomb is [ __ ] that I had one two weeks
ago
roko superstar man yeah man no matter
what people love eating fast food with -
it's delicious you will even with what
people are protesting that the landlord
is too much yeah people still pay the
rent
do you know homeless okay you know how
many people are afraid to relocate dog
you see those people every like sec
first second of the month you see them
with other [ __ ] in their truck dog ain't
nobody happy in that truck
I feel like did you see that did you
guys see that car chase window the RV
and then these two dogs flew out the
window
hello I think I saw the truck last night
they took that early Impala or something
so dude we were driving to the air show
on San Fernando and this car made a left
turn coming out of a part right at us
and there was an RV with a crazier
redneck there police to be a Breaking
Bad and therefore had no windshields bro
an RV very legal no glass but this guy
that the weirder thing is that that RV
that woman stole the identity of the
woman who used to live at our house yes
and we started getting all her all her
may all of a sudden after living there
for two years
crazy ass connection isn't it weird like
we start getting all this woman's mail
everything not just like junk mail but
like bills and stuff recent mail and it
was coming to our house and new stuff
from her transactions and purchases
whatever she's been new stuff but what
had happened was her wallet got stolen I
had to Google to find her the post
office didn't know how to find her
because they couldn't afford her address
cuz her address was registered to back
from our eyes again yeah so I found it
through a Google search in my
neighborhood and I found her ex-husband
he sent her the mail Eric called her and
then she was like I can't believe she
was so appreciative she found out they
they opened it they bought an RV for
fifteen thousand dollars and it's that
RV once upon a creator identity and they
charged all this there was one little
pit bull out the window yeah jump this
was Bush used to live
smoking Mad Dog that's a mad Tweaker
[ __ ] right there dude what did you get
deep about what did I miss was waiting
for game talk about Miss Emma tell me
about them no matter what I people
complain about while was going over them
agree to avoid going down with any
reasons that was low China by Greenland
for five hundred twenty three billion
dollars they said hell no and today here
now he's a king of Israel I cry Savino
yeah those ladies got weren't allowed
inside and it's all tied into that menu
yes exactly my whole thing is I was
that's a case and go run 2020 in Israel
bro good night yeah whoever there that's
another crooked ass dude there's a lot
of people who complain about presidents
rub their in a their in a try
tax bracket that benefiting oh yeah oh
I'll totally against it but you but your
taxes say otherwise everybody huh to
[ __ ] like Maury Povich you say your
men about truck wait a minute
what are your taxes a oh you paid less
money than a guy that has three jobs
everybody every actor out there that's
made up over a 1.5 million dollars it's
benefiting bro I don't care how much I'm
gonna complain that things ain't going
right let me tell you man things are
going ok for you that's your task of
going badass
yeah bring up that megahorn a but you're
making money you're paying less taxes
you're benefiting from all that [ __ ] you
ain't give you no money away where's my
[ __ ] envelope remember one really bro
you ain't out there giving out water to
Flint [ __ ] I don't see you
buying a [ __ ] truck filling it up
with water dropping it off exactly it's
what we got blankets to the homeless
people [ __ ] okay but you're
rewriting the camera austerity is wrong
so we don't the country going downhill
bro
well the country's going down hill are
you going uphill bro gotta stay relevant
yeah they learn being from the camera
okay they're acting no come on Trump hey
Latino but he loves Ridgeway you know
I'll read for ya it doesn't matter what
color you are
could be a Latino at 1.5 million and
then say you know what troubling a new
king bro he'll retreat you so you don't
even know he's secretly hanging out with
the owner of the Angels dog come on bro
that is dinner for Trump it cost
$250,000 a plate and the guy who the guy
to head to dinner he owns
he's like a shareholder of these uh of
these Chinese restaurant owned by a guy
named
that Danny child with the other guy
sambal last time who another Chinese guy
well I change the channel another
Chinese guy house the only big why he
gave all his money on the profits for
that day to charity from are like ten
restaurants
yeah that's mad baller [ __ ] though dawg
$250,000 of play it can't be over there
front and dog trying to [ __ ] right
everybody who is Jose
- can't afford it - Casey wants to go
easiiy what to George Bush's dinner for
10 G's right Ron Ronald Reagan Reagan
[ __ ] the game say yeah Gerald I can't
even get he said get rid of Christmas
party top three figures of good DJ Rubin
rule was so full we have Gabriel right
here Pinero no history of buddies homie
18 or 13 years ago I was there at that
[ __ ] now Laugh Factory right and do a
lot of dudes from a lot stro little
group on the a18 like san fernando
Pacoima or leader burbank guys i don't
know who was who broke but there were
deep and then I saw this fool wearing
what a [ __ ] our baby JCPenney t-shirt
you the one the total wear yeah a baby
Stanford grad and a little tank top and
that's where the same jewelry as right
now a cell phone [ __ ] bro a bunch of
hos so foo got beat up outside I don't
know we got be the first iPod or
whatever somebody just grabbed this fool
put over their shoulders and took our
boys both doing the phone
thanks did I go back to I go to the
carbon stored hangout and I guess there
was no car I get it the show was over
the Laugh Factory
so I started forth accomplished or two
with the same fools say Oh shame then
Eddie Griffin
new hearing [ __ ] I'll kill enough of my
homie right there bad he got he was that
other leg ain't a real leg he oh that
was gangsta is a real OG because you
were the video together right we did a
movie all about the money together I got
excited because they actually I get to
speak Spanish and English my first time
so you from bet from Pacoima Pacoima
represent the lovely city of Boca my
heels up over there the mountains like
my homies grandma's pie it looks
beautiful
well you can see like the mountain did
you see the clouds on the mountain looks
like you're like on some Nat Geo become
a dry well that light man growing up um
it was cool I mean it was it was um
pretty smooth but there was a large
Macaulay like yeah everybody had their
own little crowds so some people try to
bully somebody in who you believe um I
want to say in elementary like way back
like let me let me try day like a little
bit but in a bully back so it's kind of
like baby 50 but they were convinced cuz
I guess I was a lot tinier younger they
just thought that could be me you tiny
before in school that they might I was
smaller yeah so they're like man you're
like girlfriend's um a lot of lady
friends say that loving friends your
brother sisters
yeah there's seven of us it's God you
know I'm the only one the only one
there's uh three boys and four girls Wow
yeah we deep in like 17 nephews my niece
has a baby song Maddy all in Pacoima I'm
gay bro I'm a gay bro we're uh we're
shooting a show the other four adults
will really get to know about it will be
out next year but um he wasn't like my
meaning meat to the whole show stuff
coming out good stuff rubber oh hell
yeah bad
you're gonna love it bro marry hilarious
the food do those studs you will you
were our future C's right yeah yeah yeah
talk about that yeah you turn you're so
happy to show Kim the Netflix yeah yeah
II love feedback now yeah it's um back
to game making a comeback it's a it's a
cap wrench over um I do um I do besides
of being an actor I do a lot of creature
work like I'm a creature actor and a lot
of other little people it requires a lot
of work some people can't do it if you
crossed a phobic or you can't handle it
or you sometimes you can't even eat
right cuz you're like prosthetics you
can't even eat yeah so I have a routine
where I drink a little bit of water
before they do my makeup or I eat a
little bit because I know I'm gonna be
stuck for a long time so my job is to
just stuff like these crazy creatures
and there's like hidden cameras and your
best friend the people you trust all the
ones that set you up so my job is just
give you a heart attack
so really good so I did I did a couple
of those you know it's my first prank
show and ever since that I've been doing
other pranks you know every other shows
hires me and we're making a comeback so
hopefully we do some new ones you know
I'm so so far so good
scared taxes it's a good show man feel
like it is a good show I watched a few
episodes this morning in Pacoima man
just like I think Robin pecan but I have
to go to the daily meeting the kind of
the what they call it a meeting and
Pacoima projects yeah I think is when
people have like I guess you know
Kendall a bad bad on what do you call
that not as alcohol but I guess your
chance Mike Kandel got it right like
everybody has a candle you turn it on
when it's time to talk it's a
candlelight vigil meeting there in
Pacoima and um and people don't know Lee
but performance to have a lot of crypts
back in the day la black people brought
when they were deep because their family
who all connected to the good job
Michael Douglas Lockheed so the
grandparent worked her all that she
disappeared bro all that was left was
one crib yeah a lot grips right kkoma
grips my homies
blood that's my rose rose tea we're set
Fernando no employment bro like I gotta
they got a mix of the cream suit because
it's always a man was a crib so this
deal yeah
to this day that's so [ __ ] yeah
Piru bloods bro I don't want to say like
that sounds like a representative just
back them up yeah I like my home yeah so
you grew up there that I grew up there
you again
no I'll tell you real quick how it went
down hahaha no I grew up right there
like right in the heart of grammar um
like by the become a library and back in
the library
oh right right the other the other side
of the you know the borough tracks
cuz of projects and then you have the
other side so I grew up on another side
projects now the other side of the
property will meter yeah the library's
better yeah they really morally let's
let's Jeter that's nice so yeah I grew
up right there and I I didn't know a lot
of gangs from pokhara alleys and you a
few people from every clique but I'm
growing up with them they always told me
you know what you're gonna do your
Hollywood stuff you're gonna be an actor
we always got your back you don't have
to get jumped in or whatever but though
we choose me won't let you walk in and
I'm right it's like I still feel like
The Godfather book where my buddies all
reserved but I didn't really yeah but
you know what I do notice a lot of
people when you grow up in the hood you
have no choice you're there every day
every day you hang out with them and we
hang out with them they tell you hey um
it's been a while you hang out with this
it's time for you to get in or stop
hanging out with this yeah oh so but
they dig it was that choice me my one of
my buddies they give us that choice and
I go area are you down he thought about
it and he's like nevermind my you know
what never mind we've all said never
mind thank God you know that happen that
bad but I saw a respectable grandma I'm
still there by the way
and I would bump into danny trejo we
still there yeah he's a father though
yeah yeah I got em all who's about a
donor I like that so much just keep it
all I would ever care though I always
bump Mutsumi says higher to me we did
like a movie premiere for maybe that
loca they redid it and he was there and
he put mine is Esther Grammy give a
shout-out [ __ ] you Bing god I'm trying
to get 10,000 photos
hopefully you hook me up oh yeah yeah I
follow what's your Instagram name right
now baby Godfather its GP with GP so
how'd you do activate what what brought
you to acting um well you know go back
to me yeah so growing up as a child you
know you watch all these movies your
night damn how'd they do that like is it
real okay like for a minute you're like
was that the same actor but back you
know I don't know that you go were ways
and the makeup was that good right so I
grew up on watching like like the
Terminator commando and all that Conan
like oh no was one of my good idols what
you had a commando heck of a long time
do the eighties at the business Roger
here you forget well better find out
disc we beret going to kick your ass
oh you've already for breakfast the
house and I grew a tell that one dude
remember I probably only kill you last
yeah yeah who let someone like you at
the grown up you watch compiler now you
go wherever nobody showed up with a
threaded bazooka in the middle of street
shooting yeah
they just wait for him in the island he
a dead guy in a play for 17 hours
yes what happened so I grew up watching
movies and I said you know what I want
to be an actor like I want to do my own
action and do whatever these big guys
conduct do the same thing so next I
started like like doing my research and
I will go like for some spots you go
take photos and it wasn't easy because
you know they promise you all will get
your audition interview yeah exactly
hundred bucks yeah so mom I wasn't
driving my mom took me to all these
photos they kept the money I was like
350 back in the days a lot of money yes
you know so they moved out and so it
didn't happen but but but once again I
didn't give up I told my mom you know am
I gonna give up so we keep doing it
doing it my mom almost gave up and I
went on my own when I started did stuff
and then and I just kept you know my
friend invited me well the first thing
man my first project Chuckie yeah I
would have an awesome I did a photo
shoot for dragonfly really me tell you
story about that so so my homegirl was
like any music videos I should like a
little backup dancers she said hey
Gabriel I got this on this person wants
to using the music no she chose to use
you for a photo magazine and I my she
said it's for kids so okay I'm gonna
model kids girls right I get to the job
and I'm licking I see these girls in
lingerie I might so it's called dragon
flies so it's it's a magazine for
surfers but I thought it was kids
clothes right right so once again my
mouth with me remember I'm Billy 14 so
not miles with me so my mom goes to me
to the to the shoot we go to the hotel
these girls are getting jeter
wearing rounds already you know you can
see and I'm like wait a minute
so my job is no shirt just weighing
shorts I won the bed they're kissing me
my daughter just sit there and enjoy it
and take photos and then the guys I hate
can you have no at the camera light so
my mom is everything right so my mama
dick with the light going like that
helping the camera crew that my mom was
here but woman do that's my job right I
stayed the parolee
but you know what I did without a do and
keep getting bids up to that just keep
going you know never give up that's good
though your first one right
these are you want a video for the video
for those habits
here comes on ones then I did Cyprus to
dr. greenthumb lovely little ring yeah
okay put up from my mini a man now raise
the roof to let grew it was amazing I
got to hang out with the Oscar people
that I grew up in leader rescue Tyson
yeah right double the old school to
light crew Ice Cube Whizzer
God Danny go back in watch video all
those people over there I was with a
principal in high school gotta keep it
real man cuz it does leak out
oh [ __ ] yeah don't be don't catch you
man to happen right now
don't be s just keep it real and we'll
hope pray for the before I saw you at
the thing we did yeah what are you doing
before that um I just finished another
prank show for Netflix this one's
actually is Netflix Netflix my first
time working for Netflix it's I can we
talk too much but I gotta say it's the
little kid on Gaytan we have a project
together I saw that on your Instagram
yeah you have a video yeah and then you
have the scary music
yeah we're talking coming soon it's just
another prank show I mean I guess I'm
the king of pranks a show car vh1 40th
countdown they take 40 Shores
around the world and I won it four times
scare tactics for time off no mascara
gargoyles anything little bit Papa does
weird like gnomes in the gardens you
know some people have a phobia like
gardening I didn't know it's on Netflix
right now no no sweet gnomes you know my
sweet there was a horror movie of gnomes
right it wasn't I think I'm liking it
like yeah the mix of all stuff coming
now I'm excited you know hey so when you
were in high school do they treat you
like the star the high schools after it
like they started realizing you were
[ __ ] when you were like going to
school yeah this awesome beautiful
teacher by the way she was amazing she
was I want to be a video I'll tell you
real quick
I was I was getting ready to go to prom
right and she found out my date was a
little older than me you know she's like
I heard you're going to prom with the
girl that's older than you and she goes
I would have win with you I'm like well
she look like a Barbie by the way she
didn't look like a teacher amazing but
she was really nice she knew my career
she said you're gonna be a big actor
doing about it so sure let me leave
early to go do my videos and all my my
future films then I'll come back and
everybody was like you know I always
thought like Ritchie Valens but I wasn't
seeing her after like that because I
went through several high school so it
was beautiful high school was amazing I
loved it yeah wish I could go back it
had a good time
how many moons you've been in it's more
than we can count
yeah me neither more than one I've done
a lot of movie but only to chemo maybe
20 for sure but I've been a lot I do
movies TV show commercials you do three
kids um sometimes it's been a while
well that later will
like it's crazy because you're doing
more so I did window in to find somebody
to do it for me yeah yeah oh yeah or you
jump off you jump off we're gonna give
you camera phone
we don't say nothing United that was a
[ __ ] fingers working I don't be noted
but I always looked around when they're
pulling wire workers she could get loose
man that's not Curtis Mayfield ID right
yeah he died with a lighting rig so
that's my first accident you know that's
it well my dad was a piano laying on me
like you want to you want to coach the
cartoon here little every time Bugs
Bunny Elmer Fudd Daffy Duck there was a
theater and those were full of sound a
back to the sand will fall bro I've been
in the theater question for you guys if
you guys were to be in a movie what kind
of movie you guys being like your dream
like what dream movie will you guys like
to be la be a sidekick road bump off
giving heart brought up in a rock ha ha
ha
dramatic movie like a gangster movie I
won't be like a fun stoner movie that's
khalessi that about you bro porn
shown the Paletta I think my dream is
snapchat porn I would love to be one of
those fasteners movie because my passion
besides we're gonna do action besides
working out guys stay in shape I like
them I like muscle cars I like classic
muscle cars yes so I would love to be in
a fashion and furs or any fast movie you
know I'll be cool right little black
bass bar [ __ ] yeah my drift
the race is in Mission Hills like Java
Camaros it was born that's my dream
let's make some phone calls see what
happens thank you I know you love
working that show we were on oh I love
the man I just said that I wish we could
do more right it was was cool I loved it
was fun a lot of fun
hello do you enjoy the food they have a
place in where you shoot no food yeah
yeah some people get down catering some
without our amazing food Wow some are
super wack some some don't even have
nothing you're like did you do you mind
yeah thank God hey before I got here by
the way right I get to eat cereal
well I asked for the answer you wanted
to believe in the ask for a screen I
have a go at being cream cheese and it
when I got the bagel and I felt like
they've even put another liberal right
it was just painted white I like cream
cheese mix I just asked for a bagel
cream cheese
I want the cream cheese to look like the
frosting a cake bro right just put I'll
even think he pulled one bro just
painted it white and gave it to me
right like a Philadelphia will real milk
not that watered down on chocolate real
milk and it comes with the red the PA ha
if I will not obedient I'll be [ __ ]
up chocolate quick that's my [ __ ] oh
yeah oh yeah Mexico
I like the Mexicans there's been too
long chuckle me on Mexico means
delicious
yeah member the strawberry well you
don't get too much strawberry Quik I
like strawberry Nesquik yeah that's my
favorite but you like your chocolate to
be chocolatey or you like a mostly milk
chocolate like like when you would get
up and you get just Coolidge at school
and he asked you why triple chocolate
you have to cut it up if I had a cookie
I can't eat chocolate milk that's true
yeah I can't or I would trade up I will
trace out of a sandwich for a chocolate
no you won't you know Chuck a good ass
cold chocolate milk
warm chocolate brownie no now like right
now Molly do it now but yeah we talked
about like my mother typically breaking
the rules that I dip in my seat
especially when you eat cereal like like
foodie pebbles the chocolate one you
drink that milk is it struck already
yeah I ate a bowl of Trixie over two
weeks ago let me tell you my tricks and
I am fruitier and sugar around the world
around the world is flat the shape of
the fruit I just think you probably
didn't notice how much sugar were you
reading before maybe that's when you
stopped eating as my pocket shrinks and
that's we saw some Apple Jacks I was ice
of the right but uh what the was your
first zero game Cinnamon Toast Crunch
yeah that's palm to dog man cornflakes
with some banana that's what and then
some sugar you guys are poor sure got
the corn I never got any remember
watching original movie it was called
that was the rest of it me Louis
and he there was a snip with a stepmom
and to get from the Lost Boys brow
Patrick something Robert Jason Patric
Jason Patric
see reality he taught us that mom or mom
how come you never buy the frosted flake
you want sugar you wanna [ __ ] sugar
and she put all that sugar in there bro
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
what kind of show you watch growing
those who like me
that would ever be an actor like the
movies or TV shows to shows TV shows I
want to say yeah the Hulk Dukes of
Hazzard monsters yeah the monsters
Dukes of Hazzard Dukes of Hazzard was a
good one
so I'm 1818 Knight Riders over there
whereas he was you know what I knew
that'd be wise man the half octave the
personality of the world right remember
the fall guy top man right
what about Sherlock Street huh yeah but
it's just that Knight Rider boy you see
it's like a street bike right Oh
sweetheart was that guy from probably
was but I remember the bike it's not an
animal know that sweetheart was that
actor that was that he died but he was
supposed to be a big-time actor uh he
was in a mechanic's blond hair
wait what about Airwolf that Jer woof
that's it was Jan Michael Vincent
Airwolf
the original Brad Pitt yeah he got in
that accident and they're like something
[ __ ] up in his head they went weird so
anyway you have kids you're married have
one son his name is Princeton Pimentel
he'll be 16 yeah big boys bigger than me
already make super big so fast man but
yeah don't super single I'm still
looking for my queen cuz I am a Leo
still leave a season right
personality between this guy I'm always
learning by the way you know I am trying
to be a salmon happen we met we talked
about have you ever been to the little
person connection I had talked to him
about you one time I see you know I have
a friend by Noah guy from the valley
friends now together little guys - I
might have seen this guy but then you
said I'd never been to him he never been
to a convention right I've been to you
too but it's been a long time I would
like the last time I I just came out
from Frisco yeah want me to tell okay
the first time was in Seattle which was
12 years ago because I bomb it's is
another person he's obviously used in
Seattle and I go how long has it been
he think it's been 12 years of my vow so
the first time I went on my older
brother so everybody I guess they felt
like I brought my bodyguard / well he
kinda is
you know never alone cuz you never know
and it was cool but I felt like their
little intimidated by me something hi
and that's what a few but I didn't make
that connection like I thought I was you
know it just didn't happen it was cool
but I feel like little girls are tougher
than tall girls love you asked me why
did only tall girls all cuz there's more
tall girls and other ones it really is
more but I think it's like a little
easier you look like a leg man dog yeah
oh I don't mind I'm so trying I went a
second time and it is really hard it's
hard to crack that cookies I'm just
trying to be a friend see what happens
I'm not even know you know you know
thirst on my heel is his dance it's not
you argue in the red flowers
blowing kisses but I'm not gonna give up
man i'ma have to keep going and
hopefully I find my little Queen you
know yeah I got a little I got a little
hunger like I said yo bro I heard name
was a drupe rista cool yeah yeah she's
fine as [ __ ] awesome so I tried it just
it's cool though yo
I don't doesn't bother me what was doing
this project will guarantee new now
after we did our show um I'm guessing
maybe more prank shows that's what I'm
guessing hopefully your feature film we
could do together
who knows oh yeah bro lots of spooky
right after nowadays you have to like do
your own thing yeah Ming let don't be
afraid look it's gonna work because when
I do certain projects they're like hey
we don't know if it's gonna work I'm
like well you hired me I'll make it work
certain training on project like I did
one prank where they you're trying to
figure out I was supposed to be a turkey
or real turkey that you know attacks you
later like Oh Brooke Turkey that's good
so they hired me to do another prank and
I hey man if you have time we're trying
to do another prank
before you leave so they were like doing
fittings measurements they hired another
little guy but he was too big he
couldn't do it so they the guy still
couldn't figure it out and it finally
like you know what we'll call you about
a night and I'm like I'm gonna go in my
head I was like prank somebody it's a
turkey right so next you know um we on
the guy he made the dope ass costume and
some big buff guy he brought me in a big
table I'm a turkey
they put fake stuffing kind of like me
so here comes a turkey and it looks real
right because they put fake stuffing and
it's real the guy that I was getting
pranked had no idea
and right before they cut the turkey I
get on all fours and I run off the table
like this and I jump on you one of the
guys bleep oh yeah the other guy didn't
no way oh crap I thought I thought it
was rural you gotta even cook you're
right all I want it so they started the
season a lawanna was his turkey print
and I made it happen so that kind of
like I don't wanna print but just Turkey
when I was a little like let me see and
somehow boom and look here that
preseason
a me so we I'm gonna do my own show man
oh yeah this ways we go in there for one
thing but it's like everything I do for
pranks they get more episodes more
seasons I'm like that I could just do
that myself
the little show right where I drop do
the holes and then Bam Bam Bam men on
the streets right I don't know like a
discrete acts remember I'm Satan's baby
so being born I'm like wait a minute I'm
not that little but it worked
people believe this girl was giving
birth and I was a little seating baby
boy damn what they get scared oh yeah
the black woman her mom set her up I
don't see the people you trust sexual
she's like I believe in God that's
available I praise gon do people do
other little people ever give you [ __ ]
about roles that you take yeah that you
do yeah exploitative yeah yeah I'll give
you example like I'll walk you through
like you know I saw addition sometimes I
don't mind cuz I like to me to bleed
forever with them some people don't like
to audition I like to other if I don't
know what I'm dealing with
so when I go to auditions is you know I
always say break your leg good I said
good luck to everybody may the best man
win
may the best woman you know when and
they look at me they all make faces some
sense or don't me say what's up I'm like
you know what I wish they can hire all
of us but what do I'm gonna do I like
when I work with other little people but
sometimes the only one one well yes
sometimes I feel like it said that it's
a lot of competition but I'm gonna get
any me do you talk to Holly you got
skills yeah what do you wanna do I'm
gonna do my job you know I'm here to do
what I want to do and I give it one 2%
all my projects you know because I want
to come back because I love what I do
yeah and yeah people do hate they won't
tell you but you know it is a team and
so what I do
one of them's sometimes you gotta be a
little better than than the haters got
to be better than the haters you know
one step ahead of the game
yeah you gotta ignore it and just do you
cuz they don't ruin your day don't drop
that negative energy exactly there's a
tunnel vision that you're a man of
virtue oil uh we worked together cup of
time yeah um it's funny we met Emilie's
you know took his job you
shorter telling him I'm smaller than him
oh you'll be histone that right so this
is our meadow mom I did a movie called
master of disguise yeah so so I did that
I did that so it's the same company I
don't know what happened but the movie
go members part 3 of Austin Powers
I don't know went down but they call me
and I hey Gabriel you down into this
movie now you know where the whole world
thinks I'm him
I'm down into this movie you know like
like I could have done it I'll go back
to home I could have been not good that
was my room for my agent at the time she
said I was too young if she would have
kept me I was 7 years old if she
would've kept me when I was a little kid
as an actor I would have got that room
but he didn't keep me but you know what
when I went back to her I was still in
high school
she's like he's never too late and it's
true guys sometimes it ain't never too
late so I don't need that money to
become Who I am you know but that was my
room it really was but what can you do
right am I gonna cry or 7 right 7 years
old when I went to go try be an actor
but they said I was too young
yeah that's when you're high you able to
[ __ ] that movie yeah yeah yeah so
national I would just for a second so
you're you they asked you to do the
third one yeah because because I had
problems I don't know what happened but
they asked me to do a third one I was
like I'm down so I worked on the trailer
before the movie I played two characters
I play the English Bobby and I did one
stunt for him I did a flip into the
little car and I was just like a mini
Austin yeah I do that so my ages I do
what you got to do do what you do they
were happy with me and in the term agent
okay here's the plan
yes we want to do one gay bro you're
seven to get all these orders
no no I went that day in that agent
would have led to yeah getting them all
yeah if that agent would have kept me as
a little kid that would have been me so
so next you know I'm I want to do my
thing I was working and once I finish
doing the trailer they uh they call my
agent I here's the plan we love Gabriel
he's amazing and professional we want to
use them and it's all right cool and
majors like all we want
is to give credit to my client gable
payments all did all the stunts they
didn't want to do that they didn't want
to give me credit that's not that one it
was credit right wasn't even money
wasn't just credit didn't want to
swallow long if it was his people or the
other movie people and they don't want
people don't know that I'm the guys
doing all that work so I just want a
credit bro so they didn't do it I didn't
I didn't do the movie they call my agent
month later oh we can't finish the
morning with all gay bro it's you know
we need him agent you know what I tell
you that it's about my clients career
it's not about the money
how about you did you fire him and we'll
finish the movie for you all I wanted
was credible so gonna happen but see you
know I didn't do it either when I met
him he was all like he didn't really say
hi to me already with the TV yeah he was
a diva he was like already bit so he
didn't really say what's up to me so but
you know what
to me I'm a telling person like we're on
the same room I just made you guys I'm
on a Mac like a stranger I'm not gonna
you know affection if he can't hear me
you're for I'm up please go like this
right he didn't do none of that
and every time we're gonna make a room
to move him away so I thought all right
you know what forget this but once again
it was in my choice they did that I was
I'm just here to do my thing so later on
he kept it cool years went by I helped
him do commercial he's added to change
Vern's added to change cuz he needed
yeah he's like thank you so much you the
man you the man that's all I wanted from
the beginning he didn't give it to me
nobody did
so I helped him do this for one reason
because he treated us the same treatment
people thought I was him on the airplane
I might he sitting over there so I want
your auto bathroom I all right whatever
boom so next No
all right like I still did my commercial
with him help them out cuz I'm a nice
guy like that but I did it to see you
know later on they hired me you know and
they did because he said he does
different things and I don't wanna get
into that but I'm more I'm a
professional I guess I grew up you know
I'm very respectful uses I don't know
you don't know it is finger we have kids
little finger pinky
yeah well now he knows bro yeah so I
don't know to me some more respect
everywhere you go
[ __ ] yeah you know Hollywood people
chatter Cavanaugh's be careful yeah put
some I saw him brought with that photo
this guy right oh yeah what to me I
don't care what race you are where you
from if you cool mean I don't care
you're awesome
what's your Instagram you want to get a
holy other ladies recommending right Oh
drew priest of man she's ready
my ice cream is GP whiz GP wi z GP yeah
we're with the world with a whole year
huh alright that's okay it's never to me
yeah man if I hear anything bro they
looking for movie that you know yeah no
agent yeah yeah who's your publicist
it's arm came or you get my opponent but
yeah yeah put you in all the movies all
the premieres I turned out premieres I
know they do like that you bring on my
my first agent
her name was Carly junior agency when
she got me like when I won she told me I
was too young right but I went back to
when I was younger she hey I remember
you is never too late
the minute I sign her I never flew in my
life I fall out Ritchie Valens again is
like the movie La Bamba I mean an your
flu you know it's a kid I'm just givin
bukhoma the plane crashes what if this
an acid yeah of course it has a little
Mexican Mexican kid always growing
negative right yeah I always cherub
rocket boy it's like a fall right so she
got my first project she's that all you
got afraid of Canada so my agent the one
that passed her by herself
no never fly alone how is being a family
member a wingman yeah any pay for
everything yeah so she got me busy bro
she was a shammy Superbook what you
doing Canada
I did a future film kind of like eat see
but it's called beer money for USA I pay
a lien it's called greeni what that guys
that say by the Bell
uh-oh it's good
but see I wasn't I was wondering 70-79
so I was a kid in the 80s Oh with all
the 80s and you know keep going cool but
yeah I mean she kept me busy bro but she
passed she goes to me she looked out for
me she makes sure you know the script
was perfect getting chat' back on me or
you know make sure they don't take
advantage she looked out for us like
big-time yeah and it's been like up and
down you know they said you have to
promote yourself you know yeah
everybody's like I got some drivers I
hang out so any spots like I'll tell you
about Rob Zombie yeah I worked with him
and I did which is historical
Halloweentown because I feel like action
figures they I love Halloween by the way
[ __ ] yeah 21 day I do a scary movie were
they make match and figure right waiting
for that so I went to Halle we saw one
of the spore she recognized me from
scare tactics she said are you like the
famous rat boy how am i yeah that's me
the monster is that well my husband
worked with you before him I think he
has he said you got a resume I went to
my car yeah my resume picture um
several months later an apt audition Rob
Zombie movie the Lords of Salem
it was his wife no no um oh that's cool
yeah but I got to meet his wife Rob
Zombie's wife awesome in the shoot oh
yeah on fire keeps me busy when you can
man so so far so good but once again I
got that job on my own but sometimes I
tell other actors even though you got
jobs on your own you still gotta
involved your agent just in case you
have to keep it professional sometimes
you know sometimes there to pull a
minute but I'm what you like if you're
doing all the work
yeah yeah it becomes a repeat like all
the time so that we arrive at your
audition or they give it to you no they
found me on like social media really
does what they call my agent
right it's not you gotta pay the cost to
be the boss
and now but um but it worked out right
it works out but you know that's cool it
is but now they know what time it is oh
yeah it's more we know I'm Jeffrey I'm
on that natural high if I want to get it
sugar rush
dr. pepper does it for me my sister no
beer yeah once Cajun no one on the
weekends I drink occasionally like if we
all drink a beer one or two but nah I
just get really bad hangovers but it was
not my thing you know some people need a
lot of gas or they lose mom that's
already in me I I get crazy snatcher oh
look at that what's your most you think
yeah what's the most um but what was
actually a failure to you have that you
say this one I'll never sell which was
that one okay what's valuable I would
never sell yeah it's all right here the
one that you gonna be holding on to in
the world and I want to see there's a
Rob Zombie one they all signed it it's
like the the Devil's Rejects a little
they all signed it Arnold Schwarzenegger
with with with with
worth with some of the cast members I
comic-con in San Jose
no charge it three the different - no -
Patrick Arnold Arnold wasn't it like a
hundred you know funny I have too many
other action figures and have corn and
swords and have the original poster have
all this stuff but then it didn't it so
I mean I'm gonna be honest if you see me
the streets well my action figure or
anything cuz actually I have a shirt I
brand myself it's called a little man
I'm a thousand faces I gotta give you
stickers later oh yeah so I wanna hook
you uh please don't touch so you said
you you travel with a bodyguard or a
personal yeah I'm do people do you do
that because people like bother you or
they feel comfortable like messing with
you
like what's the are you just using that
person as an assistant or something no I
use a mother assistant because sometimes
when you're in an airplane I actually
can't reach shooting things right and
then some people when they see you with
somebody else they're they're very
careful how you approach me right they
see me alone so people are like okay
he's alone touchy
like big crowd so but it just looks a
little bit more it helps to people like
beating about it twice because you never
know there is no JB wanna be in somebody
in that car that's not in a camera and
you don't know what you like in
Hollywood Hollywood parties new rap
parties a pervert or somebody even as a
teenager to someone I got stoppers yeah
or or like somebody who's about to surly
you ever sleep with a director to be in
the movie
Oh somebody tries to make a movie no one
wants to play with the cheeto no nobody
ever approached me like that ally you're
driven Tommy oh I don't port yeah no I'm
not
I never tell you they were talking last
week or the week before and they all had
a story I picked a couple wrap parties
in it's it's it's different man but like
you said growing up a grandma I been to
something about your boogies I already
saw I said know them I would have seen
it's a lot of people to have in the
house George is now and I don't you know
I see these nice bold and hey you want
to put something on them and then you
get off yeah yeah now people start
drinking alcohol and you forget it's a
work phone like what is he 14 what is
that it makes all your bad genes go away
like man I haven't been around they
haven't asked me anything
you know I've been I've been awesome
stuff like you know what if I go to a
job and I feel disrespected my agent saw
me while back if you feel come the more
you want to be there you know you could
leave you know you're not to be there
they broke the rules if you respecting
you you're not comfortable I'm not gonna
do it
how many music videos Big Ben on like
more than 25 yeah yeah they all pay well
Jimmy music videos they're okay they
don't really pay good don't even don't
anyway you make money if you're the
singer yourself you know but but then
it's also coming out of your money for
the record record cold hearted it's
right but once again you got a pan back
with interest
but once again wants to do that job you
got some hey look I know you guys do
this ain't my first rodeo I know you
guys take a long time to shoot the video
how about show about 12 it takes forever
yes what you guys are gonna need me all
day how about we come in or how many
asking how many all you didn't need me
how about I save you guys money
so I welcome you so video is by already
you know that way did they rush it and
they pay me and we get stuff done but if
it's a movie
take your time plan I did a TV show
called scrubs it was like it took three
days to do one episode well they were
behind I'm gonna go ahead that right
there Valley Village yeah old hospital
on I just didn't you just stay in a
trailer chillin chillin grubbing that
good brother getting paid to kill rats
in the hospital yeah so you get paid
awaits in Iran and wait right no waiting
what's up fool Roger rope with young
shows coming up Roger
oh yeah I got a show tonight at the
Terra Cotta and then that's December
10th I got that bangbang room show and
then you know just getting up every uh
everywhere I can I did the ice house for
brunch this Sunday that was sweet show
your Perez right yeah martine pass the
reins to Joe speaking of Martine wanna
know he'll be Aviv ellos joke September
10th and that's in that the life Art
Center in Riverside California a p.m. I
will be in McAllen August 23rd
Friday at the Performing Arts Center
tickets on sale now at philippi Worldcom
also Lubbock Texas Lubbock memorial
Civic Center August 24th August 30th
through September 2nd off being summer
first are being Philadelphia PA at
helium comedy club
also don't forget September 4th are
being Tijuana my hey go ahead Andy what
whoa they got a pop you're also next
Tuesday you're doing San Diego Spanish
show are you down for that Lancaster
California and a little Valley Comedy
Festival September 7 December 13 Las
Vegas Nevada Treasure Island September
14 Sacramento Cowboys on borovo
September 15 rounds almost October 22
23rd Arlington Virginia Draft House
September 27 El Paso Texas we're gonna
go over there to bail out Willie Barcena
I didn't hear all that they kept this
joke Bobby has a glow of their press
charges
whoa whoa no he's got Warren but he's
gonna have an attorney representing them
probably now in the whole process so do
you have to go to Arizona or as an
attorney
[Music]
what's our full gay bro man we're gonna
find you people want to book you for
anything what can they find you
my Instagram GP wi z with GP wiz you can
find me there you know a set price right
to give people I know tell me about
agent but people tell you man we're just
gonna have fun you say no on it oh yeah
what what people tell you can you work
with me in the pay you uh
I'm like what's it about how many many
nah what's up fool yeah man yeah here
was today